[Music]
Our Guest
is very important
to a lot of very dangerous people
I see what this is about
the Continental explores the birth of
the John MCC universe
it takes place in the 70s it really
follows young Winston who was played by
Amy McShane in the film and how he
became the head of the Continental that
we've all seen and loved in the films
looking for the man in Alaska
it's a cravat much like the John Wick
film it's kind of a parallel world the
high table the violence the fun
is this how you get to the gift shop
we're showing the early versions of the
kitchen the Speakeasy the hotel lobby
bar in the lobby spaces we have a very
interesting location which is the former
Embassy for the UK here in Budapest
kind of rewound the clock a little bit
the Continental that we meet is decrepid
it's corrupt Cormac who's running it is
amoral and vindictive shoot Mr Avery for
me sir the rules oh yeah the rules yeah
gentlemen
there's four Max office which is not
seen in the wick films no one knows it
existed cormac's penthouse suite is
actually this beautiful old building
called Museum 17 which features a very
dramatic staircase and beautiful ornate
carving and details I don't think you're
hearing me are we done here show our
guests the uh show them the elevator
the DNA of the hotel is analog in a
digital world it's like a magic building
with interest secret passages and
pneumatic tube systems
there are constantly looking for new
areas and rooms to explore
hi hi
scale wise there's this whole other side
of the hotel that you've never seen
we've built a large exterior back lot
set here at Oregon really quite an
enormous set build the crew stopped that
day it was just mind-blowing seeing that
in real life that's your Holy Grail Holy
Grail for whoever gets to it first
[Music]
foreign
as most fans will know that hotel is a
building that exists in Manhattan the
owners of the building actually refused
us permission to copy the building
exactly we leaned into it and so that's
when we added these sculptures of the
Eagles and decorative columns and things
like that we have no Authority here
whatever goes on there goes on Lucius
says that we showed in the movies like
on John MC3 where Keanu was shot off the
rooftop we were able to take the
existing design and utilize that and we
added a little bit here and there to it
so that the stunt Department could have
a really good fight in the pool
New York back then was Mayhem there was
crime gangsters the mob it was the Wild
West
we built the Chinatown as a freestanding
set that was only possible by flying
people in from different parts of the
world my father built that Dojo is
Japanese this is Chinatown
the dojo is an interesting place because
you see what looks to be of uncle or
variety studio and then it has all these
kind of secrets in it just trap door
that opens up it looks to be like it's a
bowling alley but no it's converted into
a gun range you read a scene description
that says bowling alley and they're
running a gun operation as soon as you
have a sentence like that you have an
idea for a wonderful set
strike
you know more about the inner workings
of this hotel we get to know more about
these rules more about this world
there's Easter eggs all over the place
fans will recognize the adjudicator coin
the gold coins There are rules that play
here silly boy
excommunicado that's Latin for you
you played safe on any John Wick stuff
you fall flat it has to be nuts
an amazing kind of place just in the
weight and the texture of everything
that's happening I felt like every day I
was getting a gift on Christmas oh my
God look at that problem look at that
wardrobe look at that performance and
then Christmas came and I was like this
doesn't feel anything like what I was
getting on the set
[Music]
a grand reopening
thank you